All right,
let's see what we're dealing with.
Now, I love the blue and
the minimalist approach.
Points for guessing my favorite color,
but I feel like it could do a bit more.
There aren't really any animations or
magic moments or anything.
Oh, but there's this notification.
That'll be handy and
really helps add to the experience.
Although, I'd love to see a widget or
something else to allow me to set up
a permanent weather display
that fits with my device.
But this doesn't look like what
the weather outside looks like.
I wonder how to change that.
Of course, it would be nice if I
didn't need to do this manually.
Remember that the initial experience is
often the turning point between someone
uninstalling an app and
using it every day.
Now let's see what the tablet
version looks like.
Mm-mm.
There's nothing here.
What's going on?
Oh, I'm not on Wi-Fi.
Sure would have been nice to know I
needed an internet connection and
not that the app was broken.
Okay.
Much better.
And I like the landscape layout,
with the weather details
right next to the list.
Really great use of
the extra space here.
Oh lord.
Looks like there's a few
edge cases they overlooked.
It means, Wednesday comes
around every week, after all.
It really is important to keep in mind
the huge variety of Android devices when
designing your app.
Well, I'll need to come
up with a plan of attack.
I'll check with Ian, and
between the two of us,
I'll bet we can settle on the core
of what needs to improve.
But I challenge you to take
a look at Sunshine, and
make a short list of what you think
should be done before launching the app.
Discuss your ideas in the student
forum and take note of where your list
intersects with ours as you
move through the course.